allez on y
va et ben voilà ça y est
on après 10 semaines de travaux la place
des douves à voisin le Bretonneux
affiche désormais un nouveau visage un
nouveau revêtement pour un espace plus
aéré que les Vinois ont inauguré samedi
on a fait un événement parce qu'on a
vraiment mis beaucoup de soin à
l'affaire et à la à la réhabilité et
parce qu'avant cette place était
vraiment très compliqué à utiliser parce
que des arbres qui étaient mal qui
n'étaiit pas adapté je dirais à la
dimension de la place un revêtement qui
incitait plus les habitants à venir
faire crotter leurs chiens qu'à s'y
promener donc l'aspect de la place était
vraiment pas pas attirant donc pour nous
c'est un événement la place propose
maintenant des stationnements de parking
supplémentaires en épis grâce au
revêtements l'entretien de l'espace
devrait coûter moins cher à la commune
c'est soit de l'ardoise
concassé soit du du gravillon donc
forcément il y a pas de béchage par
particulier à faire et puis les plantes
aussi demandent beaucoup moins d'eau on
essaie de faire des choses qui demandent
un entretien derrière minimal elle est
très belle elle est colorée par rapport
à avant et le le sol est beaucoup plus
pratique pour marcher que qu'avant où
c'était de un pe peu la une sorte de
terre batue voilà c'est beaucoup mieux
20 % de l'opération a été financé par un
fond de concours de CTIN en Eveline le
reste est à la charge de la commune pour
un coût total de 300000 €